François Hollande merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous merci de cette invitation
Monsieur Hollande tout le monde se
demande un peu ce qui se passe dans la
tête de Vladimir Poutine quand on voit
ce qui se passe en Ukraine vous vous
l'avez rencontré juste après votre
élection en 2012 à l'Elysée qu'est-ce
que vous retenez de cette rencontre
qu'est-ce que vous avez compris du
président russe à ce moment-là
je le reçois à l'Élysée il est de
nouveau président après quatre ans où il
s'est mis plus ou moins en retrait en
devenant Premier ministre et on
abandonnant le kremblin et il a envie
d'une revanche il a envie de rattraper
le temps perdu et il considère que
pendant les années où il n'a pas été au
pouvoir l'Occident a commis des
indéicatesse à l'égard de la Russie à
essayer de faire pression sur elle de
l'encercler de faire que c'est sécurité
ne soit pas assurée et donc il veut
m'impressionner il veut impressionner
pas simplement la France il veut
impressionner l'ensemble des pays
occidentaux en montrant que la Russie
est des retours et que il va saisir
toutes les occasions qui lui seront
donnés pour élargir ce qu'il croit être
son espace c'est à dire reconstituer ce
qui ont été les frontières de l'Union
soviétique et par ailleurs ne pas
laisser au nom de la lutte contre les
dictateurs des pays du Moyen-Orient
c'est le moment des princes arabes ne
pas laisser l'Occident obtenir des gains
diplomatiques en abattant comme en Libye
les dictateurs arabes et ensuite il y
aura
une feuille ensuite pour vous montrer un
crayon pour montrer qu'il est dans une
posture d'agressée il me demande un
papier pour qu'il puisse noter là où
sont les missiles de l'OTAN et les
menaces qui pèsent sur son propre pays
ce qu'il veut travers cette demande et
cette inscription des missiles sur un
papier ce qu'il veut me démontrer c'est
que lui-même est finalement la cible et
que contrairement à ce que prétend
l'Amérique
c'est sur la Russie que la pression
s'exerce et pas l'inverse vous l'avez
rencontré une première fois et plusieurs
fois par la suite comment était-il vous
dites il y avait pas de part de folie
chez lui selon vous
et je dois je suis pas un psychiatre je
suis un
chef de l'État donc je n'ai jamais eu le
sentiment que Vladimir Poutine était fou
où il prenait des décisions insensées il
prenait des décisions extrêmement graves
mais qui était d'une certaine façon
issue non pas de la raison mais d'un
raisonnement qu'il se faisait à lui-même
c'est-à-dire que le rapport de force
commande tout dès lors que ils croient
être dans un rapport de force favorable
il avance dès lors qu'il sent une
résistance il se retient ou recule vous
pensez qu'il pourrait aller jusqu'à
utiliser l'arme nucléaire vu que son
armée est quand même en difficulté non
non là aussi n'est pas fou il sait que
s'il utilisait nucléaire même tactique
c'est-à-dire limiter un champ de
bataille il aurait en conséquence des
retours peut-être sous forme nucléaires
ou sous une forme conventionnelle
extrêmement préjudiciable à son armée et
sûrement à sa population ce qu'il peut
faire c'est d'utiliser des armes sales
un moment il a laissé penser que c'était
les Ukrainiens qui avaient une bombe
sale qu'est-ce qu'on appelle une bombe
sale c'est du chimique ou du biologique
ou qu'est-ce qui peut faire c'est
bombarder pas loin d'une centrale
nucléaire ça il peut le faire mais
utiliser l'arme nucléaire non il y a
encore des interdits heureusement dans
dans la vie internationale parce que
nous sommes dans le régime de la
dissuasion vous dites en 2012 a été
cette année de bascule à ce point de
bascule se tournant dans l'ordre
international pourquoi non seulement
l'arrivée de Poutine mais il y a aussi
l'arrivée de sissippi en Chine comme
secrétaire général du Parti communiste
et comme président de la Chine et
qu'est-ce qui se passe à ce moment-là en
2012 il y a une alliance qui se forme
entre Poutine et ses civil alors qu'il y
a toujours eu des formes de rivalité
entre la Russie la Chine il y en a eu
quelques fois des conflits territoriaux
là entre ces deux présidents il y a une
véritable amitié au sens de celle des
chefs d'État c'est à dire d'intérêt
commun et une alliance qui se forme il
se verront considérablement fréquemment
toujours ça tient toujours
et même si la Chine n'a pas forcément
approuvé l'intervention russe en Ukraine
enfin c'est ce qu'elle prétend elle
continue d'aider d'une multiple façons
la Russie d'abord
du gaz du pétrole en lui fournissant des
moyens de contourner les sanctions
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a cette grande
alliance ce que j'appelle la grande
alliance entre la Chine et la Russie
avec deux pays qui se vivent ça peut
nous paraître étrange mais ce qui se
vive frustré humilié par par les
Occidentaux donc il faut bien comprendre
que ces deux systèmes ces deux régimes
ces deux grands pays aussi et Chine
pensent que nous sommes
déclinants que nous sommes
décadents que c'est terminé le temps des
démocraties et que c'est le temps des
régimes autoritaires qui est dangereux
ça si vous dites le nouveau
bouleversement de la planète commence
par le défi lancé à nos valeurs de
liberté des tas de droits de démocratie
par ces nouveaux empires oui parce que
ces nouveaux empires pensent que le
système démocratique est un système
finalement de division de de de
surenchères de compétition dépassée et
d'affai déplacements pour décider du
sort du monde alors que eux pensent être
d'une certaine façon insaisissable et
donc inattaquable mais parallèlement à
ça et peut-être pour
que monter de ses empires comme vous
dites c'est le retrait des États-Unis on
sent le retrait des États-Unis et
évidemment il y a ce recul de Barack
Obama
sur la série cette fameuse ligne rouge
qu'il avait tracé pourtant vous dites
une erreur c'était une erreur pour vous
dire nous étions prêts à le faire
ensemble s'achissez pas d'une
intervention au sol je sais pas de
reproduire ce qui s'était fait en Irak
il s'agissait de punir Bachar al-Assad
nous savions qu'il avait utilisé des
armes chimiques nous avions les preuves
que il avait sciemment bombardé sa
population
savait lui-même qu'il allait en courir
les foudres et quand on promet la foudre
et qu'on évoque une ligne rouge et que
rien ne se produit même si il voulait
Barack Obama consulter le Congrès des
États-Unis c'était tout à fait
respectable et j'ai j'ai admis cet
argument mais c'est je lui ai dit mais
si on vous consultez votre congrès ce
sera trop tard on peut pas trois
semaines ou un mois après que le pire
était commis
tout à coup décidé
ce sera protégé contre toute
intervention extérieure en décidant de
se retirer de tous ces pays lointains
notamment l'Afghanistan toutes les
puissances occidentales se sont retirées
finalement mais alors on fait quoi quand
on voit une chape de plomb qui qui
retombe sur les femmes afghans en ce
moment après toutes ces années où on a
été où les pays occidentaux ont été
impliqués on fait quoi on laisse faire
c'est c'est l'indifférence
en Afghanistan on dit ce qui se produit
en Iran avec les femmes qui demandent
tout simplement d'être libre et de
pouvoir de ne pas mettre un voile
puisque veulent en décider elle-même
donc nous devons mettre ces pays aux
bandes des nations de l'ont pas
intervenir militairement en Iran ou en
Afghanistan je crois que voilà et révolu
mais
sanctionner les isoler faire que ces
dirigeants là ne puissent pas espérer
quelques soutiens que ce soit oui ça
fait partie de ce que nous on devait
faire les mettre de côté et montrer
d'ailleurs que leur seul allié c'est
c'est la Chine et la Russie et l'Ukraine
en terminant à ce qu'elle peut gagner
cette guerre selon vous elle a gagné la
guerre d'ores et déjà elle a montré que
qu'un peuple qu'il n'était pas le plus
puissant pouvait empêcher
un dictateur et une armée supposée être
conquérante de d'envahir et de soumettre
un pays de et de le mettre en état de de
dépendance donc cette guerre là elle est
déjà gagnée comment elle doit se finir
elle doit se finir par le retour
l'intégrité territoriale qui était
d'ailleurs dans les accords de mise
puisque vous avez signé moi-même les
accords de mise parce que quelle est la
base sur laquelle nous devons repartir
ce sont les accords de misk de 2015
on peut négocier avec lui on peut
négocier que dans un rapport de force
donc Vladimir Poutine va utiliser
l'hiver pour pour geler tous égard le
conflit et si nous cédons si nous ne
continuons pas à aider l'Ukraine et bien
au printemps il y aura sûrement des
forces politiques en Europe ou ailleurs
aux États-Unis qui diront bah arrêtons
cette guerre et négociation avec
Vladimir Poutine je pense que il faut
continuer à aider l'Ukraine que au
printemps sur le plan militaire les
ukrainiens et encore regagner un salon
de territoire qui sont occupés et
ensuite
obligeons Poutine à négocier et il
négociera pour l'instant la mobilisation
tient quoi quand même elle tient mais
c'est fragile parce que la grande
différence entre une dictature et une
démocratie c'est que nous le temps est
un matériau extrêmement rare
c'est un matériau abondant il pense les
dictateurs qu'ils ont toujours le temps
qui sont là pour toujours nous nous
savons bien que nous sommes que des que
des précaires
nous savons pourquoi nous nous battons
nous savons ce que c'est que la liberté
la démocratie et les Ukrainiens nous ont
fait la plus belle des leçons on se bat
pas simplement pour des frontières on se
bat pour un mode de vie merci beaucoup
merci à vous